Matthew I'm so sad that another you know
Survivor injury has claimed someone's
place in the game but I have to ask you
especially as a fan and watching you
this season how are you feeling now that
you've seen it all play out your injury
is hopefully healed how are you doing
yeah um you know I had surgery in
November I had a pretty massive surgery
um long laundry list of issues to kind
of correct um so I'm doing much better
I've got put in a lot of time in PT so
physically I'm I'm back there um to
where I you know need to be back to full
training mode
um but you know mentally it was it was a
it was a hard thing to watch you know
I'm not one that what like watches like
people you know like watch some videos
of fail army or people falling or
getting hurt like I don't I don't want
to see that so seeing myself you know
get hurt and struggle it was definitely
not something that um I was looking
forward to you know prior to the show
starting
um and then you know as I got to see how
they were presenting me you know I
couldn't have been happier because they
really presented me in a light that you
know didn't focus on my struggle and
really didn't show how badly I was hurt
or how much pain I was really in they
really just just focused on more on my
gameplay and I was I couldn't be more
happy you know because they really you
know I suffered out there it was not fun
and you know but you know I pushed
through and still tried to make the most
of it and still tried to move forward
with the game
yeah and I also like want to touch on as
well Jeff just said in his most recent
episode of his podcast that you know it
was your decision to take yourself out
of the game and you're not a quitter but
at one point in time were you like okay
this is the move that I have to make
because they like you said they focus a
lot on your gameplay didn't really show
the pain you were in so at what point
were you like okay this is the decision
I have to make so we had a medical
evaluation
um with Jeff and Dr will after the um
event and they don't really show that
but you know I could not raise my arm
past my shoulder level
um and I was an immense amount of pain
and so Dr will and I discussed he's like
you know I you're injured you've
obviously dislocated your shoulder twice
though these are the things that could
happen but I can't answer that question
without an x-ray an MRI a CAT scan and
we don't have those tools in the field
so to really know the extents of your
injury we need those things to happen
and because of the extent of your injury
I would pull you from the gate and so
when he told me that I said you know I
hear you
um but this is my journey and I want to
be in control of my journey so I'm going
to do the right thing and I'm going to
pull myself for the game because of my
injuries I don't want you to make that
decision for me and so it you know it's
just about about ownership of my journey
and um and just doing the right thing
yeah absolutely well I credit you for
that I know it must been so difficult
having like been such a massive fan of
the show and like having to make that
decision but props to you for handling
it so well
um but I do want to talk a little bit
about game play because like you said
they focus a lot on that and I loved
watching your strategy on the show so I
know your tribe you know you were only
had been to what one Tribal Council and
you guys were winning winning but I do
have to ask you after that first tribal
and despite winning all the challenges
like what is your mindset like do you
already have your next move like brewing
in your head of what you would do if you
went to tribal yeah oh yeah absolutely I
mean we were on the boat to tribal and
that's when I made the decision to play
my shot in the dark in a creative way
because I knew where all the votes were
going I knew exactly what was happening
and so to keep in my mind to keep the
tribe Dynamic very calm I decided to
withdraw my vote because that kept if I
voted for you know if I followed Sue
with Kanan and um and Maddie then
Brandon would have never trusted me if I
voted for Lauren then Brandon would you
know been caging like they're coming
after me so it was the best scenario
because I knew Kane would be on the outs
Janie's got to be picked up so I'm I
want to get these numbers and it kept
Brandon thinking that our alliance was
still very strong so it allowed me to
act subvertly and then start doing all
of my gameplay
yeah absolutely and speaking of gameplay
I know you left with an idol in your
pocket but you still have that fake Idol
um with Jamie who at this point in time
still thinks it's real so even though
you had to leave on unfortunate
circumstances like what was going
through your brain after being like Oh
okay this fake Idol is still out there
you know I mean it's a game where you
know everyone is a lethal Target you
know everyone can come for you at any
moment and so yeah I was aligned with
Genie and that was to um obviously build
trust because our strategic game Jamie
and I had so much in common on a
personal level but when we talked
strategy it was not happening so I had
to create I had to create trust and so
that was the conversation of like if she
finds an idol in front of me what
happens when that happens you
immediately say oh my God this is
amazing this is for us you know and that
creates that Bond and that's what I
needed because Kane was already working
with me and so I needed that third and
so I needed a strong reason for Jamie to
align with me so that's why I did it um
was to get my numbers but you know then
leaving the game you know I have you
know obviously told Carson because I'm
now trying to get cars out of my numbers
you know so now I put out in the world
that Jamie has this Idol and so you know
that is a target obviously on anyone's
back so it'll be interesting to see how
all of that plays out because you know
even me leaving the game I you know I'm
still put out information that's
probably going to have some effect on
how things play out
exactly and I can't wait to see how that
plays out and speaking of bonds I want
to quickly talk about your bond with
Carson because I know he hadn't been on
your tribe for very many days but it
seemed like you guys really had a great
Bond and friendship like what was it
about Carson that made you feel like
okay I can trust him he can I can talk
to him
um Carson is just I mean just an amazing
person he has
he obviously his intelligence is
boundless I mean he he's one of the most
intelligent people I've ever come in
contact with but he also has a huge
heart he has a big amount of compassion
um and I think that you know just
through conversation
um you know he really was genuine in in
that he was caring about me being
injured and that was something that you
know you know Maddie was very fantastic
with me in the beginning of you know I'd
wake up in the middle of the night
crying and she would give me hugs and
make sure I was okay and Carson really
picked up that like
you know that role of like being a
supportive like almost family member you
know to someone that's her and so the
bond there was very quick and you know
and something that I really I felt like
I felt like he really cared about me and
you know and
with his heart not just his head you
know what I mean and so that was that
was something that I really
um gravitated towards
um um you know because
you know I just lost my closest and
personal Ally which was Jamie and so you
know there was a void there that had to
be filled in Carson definitely you know
filled a lot of that
yeah I wish I could have seen more of
you guys together
um but I'm looking forward to seeing how
everything plays out
um I do have to ask you despite you know
I know you would probably change and as
you said not going and climbing up that
rock but aside from that is there
anything you would do differently about
your strategy or game that you played or
do you feel like that was how you wanted
to play the game you know it definitely
was how I wanted to play the game I've
gotten a lot of flack for you know after
the snake challenge you know publicly
saying I got one of those in my backyard
but you know my Mantra in my thing about
Survivor is the Survivor is a game where
there's no place to hide so why hide if
you're a threat if you're a challenge
stand up and let them know it and you
know and that's that's how I felt you
know I was so proud of myself in that
moment and you know I'm like yeah
absolutely I want you guys to know that
even with a hurt arm I'm here to compete
and it gave me the confidence boost to
you know say that I can still be
effective in this game and there are
winners that have never won an
individual immunity challenge so there
wasn't there was other routes to me
getting to the end and so
competing in that challenge having that
moment really gave me the confidence to
say okay I can still play this game
yeah yeah and I know in your exit
interview kind of at the end of the
episode last night you know and you've
said it
elsewhere as well you felt so much
stronger after leaving the show but what
would you say is your biggest takeaway
from your time in the game
I being on the show is just
it's such a huge confidence Builder
because you know you have this like
imposter syndrome you're like I don't
know if I'm you know smart or I don't
know if I'm you know likable or all of
these things and then
you put yourself out in there and and so
I've come out knowing that I am way more
intelligent than I give myself credit
for I have a huge amount of empathy and
you know for other people and that you
know
one of my one of my strongest abilities
is to connect with other people and so
you know I I am so thankful for this
journey and this experience because
it gave me a confidence level that I'd
never had before
um and it kind of solidified that you
know
um I wanted to be a great Survivor
player and I you know even injured I
still was a great Survivor player so it
just exactly you know I you know the
love for the game the love for being a
Super Fan like I feel like I gave 100
you know like Jeff said I you know I
gave 100 I was vulnerable I was a king
for it like I did I I tried my hardest
and and that's just it was me it's just
it's me as a person and it's still great
to see that you know and you know
obviously you don't often get the
opportunity to step back and see
yourself in action
um and so it was
um I mean this I knew Survivor was going
to change my life I just didn't know how
and um the internal growth was the thing
that is probably the biggest takeaway
for sure oh I love that and I love your
outlook on everything and it was such a
pleasure watching you know show when I
was devastating
State you left under those circumstances
but I'm always here to manifest you know
or return for these people who have had
injuries please please so like we need
to make it happen but um thank you so
much for your time it was lovely
chatting with you and I'm looking
forward to watching the rest of the
season and seeing what happens with this
fake Idol and seeing how it all plays
out so yeah it's it's we'll see how it
goes but it's definitely
um it's out there the information's
there so we'll see how it plays out